Hello!
Who came back?
Oh, wait, yeah, let me reply.
Let me write up my tweet back for those confused.
Um, I donated to Iron Mouse's, uh, um, Immune Deficiency Foundation, Tiltify, and, uh, uh, Doki Bird just couldn't let my funny stay.
Hold on.
I'm replying to her.
Wait, where is she?
Doki Bird.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, here we go.
Anyway, welcome!
Bit warm, though.
Yeah.
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
Not the 169.
What's her funny?
So, I, she donated $10,000, and I was like, I wonder if I can do 10,001 cents.
And it let me.
And, um,
uh, um, and then she, uh, and then she did, uh, she added an additional $1,000, and 69 cents to top me.
Not top me, one-up me.
So, I, uh, responded to her on Twitter and, you know, told her that she had to pay for the privilege to do so.
To do so.
I don't like you.
Love you, Arca!
Uh, but, um, yeah, uh, uh, whole situation kind of sucks.
Um, I debated saying this, but, um, guys, um, um, um, um, um, um, um,
um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um,
um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um Later on... what I can't... what I will say is... hey, they owe me money!
I never got paid for even the merch when I did the podcast, so... yeah... and um... for those who are very confused...
I don't know who wouldn't know at this point... but um... Ironmouse put out a video... why she left to be Shoujo... and... um... and uh... it's not good... it's not good... at all... it's very bad... um... pretty much all the members have... have... have... have... talked about it... and uh...
um... uh... people that were going to join... have talked about it... um... uh... not really... um...
uh...
you know... like I said, I will... give... many more details...
um... later on... so I don't want people to... I want to... try to have people avoid speculation... or anything like that... um... but uh... you know... I had... a lot of things... lined up... and... um... probably a lot of them are... not gonna happen...
uh...
sorry...
it's just been really stressful...
um...
we just keep on keeping on... but
uh...
I'm sorry... if... you know... I... have... nothing to show... for the next couple of... a while... uh... I can say... my...
3D concert should still happen... luckily... but uh... gosh... sorry... I didn't expect to cry... um... I... uh... kind of everything really hit me... like... yesterday... not yesterday... this morning... so... ugh... okay... sorry...
uh... uh... it's... uh... it's been really kind of crazy... watching something that you... worked on... and worked towards... for so long... kinda just... um... crumble right in front of you... literally... literally like get Thanos'd... so... um...
uh... uh... yeah... but um... uh... yeah... I'll just uh... uh... I'll just keep working hard... that's all I can do...
ugh...
yeah...
sorry to be a downer... at the very beginning of this dream... but I kinda wanted to...
I... ugh... ugh... I... ugh... ugh... I... ugh... ugh... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't... I don't...
I don't... I don't... I don't...
I don't...
I don't It's been a stressful couple of weeks, let's just say that.
It's been a stressful couple of weeks.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, my hands are shaking.
Bye.
No!
My tea just spilled all over me.
Wait.
I'm gonna go get a towel.
I'll be right back.
Ugh!
Okay!
Okay, I got that off my chest a little bit.
I...
Originally wasn't gonna say anything.
And just kind of let...
Bygones be bygones, but...
Or at least handle as much as I could in the background.
Cause I don't like to...
Bring this stuff up and...
Have you guys...
Worry about it at all.
But...
I just kind of kept getting more...
I kind of kept getting more...
Uh...
Frustrated...
At the fact that...
Um...
I felt like it would affect you guys...
If...
If I...
You know, I'm like...
Big thing's coming!
And then nothing...
Nothing ever came, so...
Um...
That's kind of where I...
Why I decided to say anything.
It's like...
Like I said, I originally was like...
It'll just be better to...
I will say more and I'll...
I'll give you guys...
I will give you guys more details...
On everything.
Just, uh...
Um...
Yeah...
For now, that's all I can tell you.
I think...
I think everybody from heaven...
Is cursed...
All I can do is laugh!
What...
What the helly?
Sorry, I'm eating my bobo.
I was like, I'm not gonna get bubble tea.
I'm not gonna get bubble tea.
I craved...
No, caved.
Sorry.
I caved because I craved.
Anyways, welcome guys back.
Hey, you too, welcome back.
Today we're playing more Blade Runner.
We're good.
Um...
We...
Are...
Back...
So, before...
I played...
Let's see...
Recap...
What happened?
Grave diving?
Um...
We...
Very...
Um...
Last time we...
We...
What's the word?
Went to...
Uh...
No, I went to...
We are...
We are McCoy.
And we're the sharpest shooter in the...
Big...
Holy cow, that scared me.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you!
Um...
I'm trying...
I see you guys are sending me lots of stuff and I'm purposefully not reading it because I don't want to cry.
Ah!
Hold on, I'm gonna turn that down.
Why is it so loud?
Never used to be so loud.
Uh...
Da da da da da da da da da da da da.
I...
I actually...
I clicked out of the thing.
Ah la la la la.
Oh.
There.
Uh...
Login.
Licks your tears like Bruno...
Who?
Buserati.
Licks sweat.
Bruno Mars?
It's a JoJo's reference.
Girl, get out of here.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
And then I go to here.
And then I turn it...
No.
I go to alert box.
And then I turn it down.
I was on...
I was on Camilla's stream today.
And...
Um...
She told me not to use...
Well, she didn't tell me not to use it.
But she said she doesn't use stream labs anymore.
She uses...
Stream elements.
And her stuff was so fancy.
Yeah, I did...
I did possess her.
I did, I did.
Yeah, I could possess her right now if I felt like it.
Yeah.
Uh...
But it was a lot of fun.
I don't know what she does with her VODs.
Uh...
Hopefully she keeps them.
Normal OBS is less CPU intense.
No, no, I use OBS.
But I use stream labs for donals.
Yeah, that's why there's the stream labs link in the...
Oh, link in the description.
Hmm...
But...
I don't...
I think...
I thought stream labs for donals versus stream labs OBS is different.
No?
Aren't they different?
I thought.
Stream elements is good for bot moderation.
Really?
Hmm...
It is different.
Oh, see?
I have no idea.
I don't...
I'm so stupid when it comes to all this stuff.
I don't know how to do anything.
Streaming.
Whatever.
Okay.
What did we do?
Well, okay.
First, there was a...
There was a murder spree of the animals at the questionable pet store.
And then...
There was a guy who worked at the place that's...
That's manufacturing...
Uh...
Stuff.
Robots.
And...
That guy...
He was in anti-gravity and he died too.
Tyrell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Happy you already.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Pro streamer.
I'm not a pro!
I'm not...
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm only five years old.
Uh...
Yeah, Hannibal too!
Then we went to that guy and he was like...
Some...
He was a guy in a really chilly room.
And then there was another guy...
Oh, and it was the...
It was...
Some replicant that killed the guy at Tyrell Corporation.
Sorry, this is the worst description ever.
My brain is...
You are the youngest person ever!
How old are you?
I'm five years old!
And, uh...
Mumbles in Chinese.
Exactly.
And then there was an explosion!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
And before the guy died, he was like, Go to the twins!
And we went to a really creepy dollhouse.
Hated that.
And now we woke up in an apartment.
And...
As Mint watched the film...
Uh, when I was like...
Two wisps old!
Jeez!
It's fine, I'm having fun.
This is where I'm at.
Yes.
Wait a second.
The Bradbury building.
I wanna look around here a little bit before...
Let's actually start here, and then we can watch the cutscene from before.
That...
That we ended on.
I think that would be good.
This creepy-ass building!
I hate in here.
This place scares me.
This place is so scary!
Run!
And then there's creepy walking dolls around here.
Hate, hate, hate.
Hate, hate, hate, hate.
I feel like I did not view everything...
In here.
This is how we go upstairs, but I don't wanna do that.
Wait.
Is this where I came from?
Yeah.
Wait a second.
Ah!
I'm sorry.
How do I...
There was other rooms.
Was it upstairs?
Pshow!
Brr!
I guess so.
Cause there's nowhere else for me to go.
Uppies!
Sorry!
Nevermind, we get the cut soon.
Okay, nevermind, we don't get to explore.
This is so sad.
I'm getting my ass kicked again.
I got yeeted!
That guy...
That guy's crazy!
What do you think he found us, man?
One of the design subcons must have talked.
Unstable personalities, to say the least.
It's creepy in the movie too.
The old block.
It would've created problems down the line.
We got problem now, man.
This one?
He's not a problem.
He's...
An opportunity.
You're weak, my friend.
I expected so much more from you.
Are you gonna kiss me?
Thinking our brother not hearing too good.
Yeah, I wonder why.
Oh, he hears us.
Isn't that right, McCoy?
You ready to give up fruitless nightmare, man?
Come back to family?
He doesn't have a choice.
He never did.
Wait, are we a replicant?
Let me kill him, man.
No.
We got no time to be patient.
Your woman, she be getting sick.
I promise you, she'll not die here on Earth.
I promise somebody will.
Believe me, he's the least of our problems.
You're talking crazy.
The hunter be dangerous.
A fool sees not the same tree a wise man sees.
I'm no fool, man.
You must have a little faith, my friend.
He said come back to family.
Without contraries is no progression.
How can you trust any of their kind?
We have been manipulated by them, correct?
Or maybe we're not.
Now they're going to see exactly what lies on the other side of the horizon.
Unless our kind means...
The po-po.
Oh, wait!
The word!
Sorry.
The thing I remember the most.
Lucy!
Right?
Lucy.
I believe.
How long have I been here, Lucy?
The man...
How do you know my name?
I saw your things at Runciter's.
Did you feel bad when they killed those animals?
They were so pretty and sweet.
I hoped father wouldn't do it.
But Mr. Runciter deserved retribution.
That's what father said.
Why?
Yeah, that guy kind of sucked.
Because...
He treated me...
Bad.
Like I belong to him.
I'm sorry.
Are you really the hunter?
Like father says?
It's my job.
Why?
What do you have against us?
Nothing, it's just...
The law.
Would you hurt me?
I promise you I won't.
A little chook.
Father will be back soon.
A little chook...
And this is where we ended before, give me one second...
Okay, we're trapped in our little chair.
This is... what actually do we do here?
Oh wait!
Something green?
Go!
You can do it!
McCoy!
Walk
500 miles and I would walk 500 more...
Just to be the man that walked a thousand miles through...
At your door...
He
didn't even move at me!
I think we actually have to leave.
Oh shoot, okay.
This way?
Where are we?
Just kidding.
Pick that!
Hold on.
Once we stop moving...
Do we have anything?
Oh, I guess...
No actual stuff, okay.
Maybe...
Maybe this steam...
Jump diagonally!
Thank you, Scarlet.
Oh, that was me, not the steam!
What are we supposed to do here?
This way!
Go back!
I should've pulled up the walkthrough.
I'm a dummy dumb.
Is this a door?
Open...
Grab this!
Please!
I can't!
And this!
This too!
Grab the teddy bear!
Go!
I'm clicking on the teddy bear.
I don't know why...
I don't know why he's going all the way over there!
Oh!
He's...
Blair Witching himself!
Why?
Maybe I clicked too many times.
Uh oh, I'm not clicking anymore.
McCoy?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
Ha ha ha!
Go!
Over here.
I don't know how to click over to the bear though.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go!
Progress!
Surely he'll be able to pick this up and surely there is a knife in there.
No!
Oh!
You can see how many times I've clicked on it.
Okay, hold on.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Are his legs cuffed?
Ha ha ha.
Can you just stand up?
I don't know.
Ha ha ha.
I'm going to...
Ha ha ha ha.
I'm going to get the walk-through up.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
Blair Witch...
No.
No, but sorry!
Blade!
Uh...
Blade Runner walk-through.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ah...
We're...
We're at... we're, I think, at Act 3, or we're just about to hit Act 3.
I would like to... finish the game today.
So, that's why I might rely a little bit on the walkthrough, or maybe... you guys.
Go back to the Blair Witch and click on him to cut the rope.
No kidding!
Are you... really?
Oh wait, there is a thing here!
It's so dark, how are you supposed to see it?
Oh my gosh, thank you, Strike.
Click.
No?
Eh?
Oh,
wow!
Okay, let's save the game.
Oh, what the... what is... what...
I hacked.
I bought this game from Steam.
Save game.
Sure, sorry.
Resume game, okay.
Nope, no, no, no, no, no.
This, this, this.
It felt and smelled like real cheese.
Dairy products were choice contraband.
Scarce and mucho expensive.
Selling them was a Class A felony.
No kidding, no kidding.
We got some cheese.
Over here.
Okay, I guess we do have to go.
Pizza!
Money.
All right, dog.
Hysteria Hall was an arcade, down near Nightclub Row.
Nothing else there.
Strange.
What, what was it?
Don't just say strange.
Explain what it is.
Nothing else there.
Okay, let's go this way.
I'm gonna get my gun out first.
You let him in my room?
They had a warrant, mister.
What was I supposed to do?
They.
Took.
My.
Pictures.
Couldn't stop them!
How about me?
You think I'm easier to stop?
Uh...
Who the hell are you?
Oh.
McCoy, LPD.
Uh-oh.
LPD, huh?
Maybe you guys can return something to me.
Haha, just put bye.
How do you know we got it?
How?
One of your own.
Vade of my property.
Bad haircut.
Stupid coat.
It's...
The other guy.
What other guy?
What's his name, Gruz?
Don't play dumb.
What about him?
Nothing.
I just thought you were gonna arrest me, that's all.
I don't care about your little run-in with the manager, okay?
I'm looking for a couple of replicants.
Can't help you there, friend.
Yeah, Guzman, Guzman.
Maybe the clerk can tell me who was renting that room back there.
Guzman?
Why were you hassling him?
He left these creeps in my room.
I'm a very private person.
What have they got against you?
Not the creeps.
Nothing, friend.
I ain't done nothing.
Friend?
We're all innocents, aren't we?
That's the most suspicious thing.
Not like people asking questions either.
Just help me out here a little more.
You seen a big Rasta guy around here?
Or a guy with a beard and dark eyes?
A Rasta?
What's that?
He's got dreadlocks.
Talks with an accent.
Oh.
No, I ain't seen no one like that.
Look.
My mother's waiting for me.
You stick around.
Maybe the manager will come back.
Wait, where did he go?
Is this a dog?
I've been looking at it the whole time.
Bing, bing!
Wait, this place seems kinda big.
We got over here?
Whoa!
I didn't know who was working this side of the pool.
But whoever it was, they'd been pretty thorough going through the joint.
I doubted if there was anything I could find that hadn't already been snagged and bagged.
Snagged and bagged.
Wait, but what is this place?
Oh, we got...
Something.
And we got...
Nothing.
Thanks for clarifying, officer.
Chill!
Thank you!
Thank you, guys.
Really...
Nothing.
Appreciate it.
Don't feel like you have to donate or anything.
Please.
It's the last thing I want.
Oh,
what happened to the dock?
Oh my god!
They...
This is what happened...
Back to the Future 6.
Oh...
Crossover with Blade Runner.
Nooo!
Oh my god!
Gotcha for...
Hot Dog.
Not Hot Dog.
What, are my chews not good enough for you?
Wait a second.
Before we go...
Because there was some stuff in the rooms, too.
There was one more room.
I didn't realize that this would go downstairs.
This room here.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
We're here!
Wait...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
If we made a whole circle...
This is where that got...
If we keep going, we'll head...
We'll be at...
We'll be at sushi!
Oh sh...
Oh gosh...
I didn't mean to go down the stairs.
He's so slow.
Come
on, you're the five gifted dog!
Okay...
Let's go back.
We'll...
Keep going this way then.
Okay...
Ever injured yourself eating pizza?
Oh!
It's like scratching your throat with the crust?
Yeah...
I have done that before.
Crazy...
Okay...
I can't take the keys or anything.
Doesn't seem there's so much in here.
I will save so we don't have to go through all that again.
And...
Yeah, we'll just override this.
Um...
Are we gonna explore the car?
Or...
The car looked a lot like the one I'd been tracking.
The driver had been smart enough to pull the license plate, but the vehicle identification number was still there.
Not the VIN!
If I ran it through the mainframe back at the station, I could ID the owner.
Ah!
We have that then!
Ripper Odie and Cheese, brother!
Oh, we have two places we can go.
Let's try this way.
We're here!
Oh my gosh!
Okay...
And then what's this way?
This is maybe sushi?
Sushi!
Oh, it's so far away.
Yeah!
We're at sushi!
Oh my gosh!
We made like the biggest circle ever.
What, LA's like...
Two feet wide?
What is this?
2019 LA is really walkable.
Yeah.
Clearly.
I need to ask you...
McCoy, be more assertive!
Assume myself...
Uh...
Onisha!
Ray McCoy.
Repeat that.
Be more assertive, Mr...
Okay.
Where's our car?
Where did we leave it?
Where did we park our car at?
Uh...
Longtime lurker!
Wow!
Thank you so much for the...
Pink!
Ah!
Excuse me, pal.
Oh, okay.
I thought he was gonna come to kill me.
Just kidding.
Wait, no.
Okay.
Our car...
Uh...
Where would it be?
Hey, pal.
You could've done something when that goon had me by the throat.
Call the cops, at least.
I am the cops!
You're still walking and breathing, aren't you?
Damn!
That ain't the point.
You scratch our back, we'll scratch yours.
Nice friggin' policy.
You don't like it?
Get a permit somewhere else.
Lousy cops.
Down the hall, on your left.
What?
You're a cop, right?
Your buddies have already been here.
Room 27.
What were they doing here?
I don't ask a lot of questions when a badge is shoved in my face.
You have a big guy with a strange-looking mustache staying here?
DNA row?
He worked at Howie Lee's around the corner.
Okay.
Thank you.
We'll go check the- I don't break a lot of bread with the class of people that pass through here.
But if you want to look around, check out some rooms.
I break fast.
Be my guest.
Yo, this place is a dump, mister!
The room I stayed in, it's leaking!
Did we get everything in this room, now that I think about it?
There was just this drawer.
Sorry, I came back here.
I think so.
And we got something mysterious in there.
I don't know what it was.
How did I get to...
Uh...
I think it was outside.
Right?
And then we went here.
There.
And this should be DNA.
You can ring the bell while you're standing there, can you?
Excuse me, pal.
My name is Nancy McCoy Drew.
We're just walking.
Okay.
Gosh, that was the longest cutscene ever.
Am I too big, by the way?
Ah, our house!
I mean...
This is our house, yes.
Our...
Night...
That's right!
We need to go to Nightclub Row, baby!
But...
He did say he wanted to run the VIN at the police station.
So let's do that.
I like Big Minky.
I'm big in Japan.
I...
What were those shirts?
Do you guys remember those?
The I'm big in Japan shirts?
What the heck does that mean?
Ground floor.
Mainframe and shooting range.
Another retirement in the fourth sector today as a Blade Runner shot an alleged replicant in the middle of a crowded street.
This lady is so loud.
Shut up.
Is this the guy that'll run the VIN?
You keeping busy, pal?
Hey!
Nah, the place has been pretty quiet the last couple of days.
Where can I run the VIN?
In the...
In this room?
In here?
The esper?
The esper...
It was a song.
Oh, was it?
What?
Moon bus.
Moon bus!
Whoa!
Guess you could say...
Being nosy for new punk rock.
Oh, what is this vampire?
Moon bus.
A moon bus?
That guy sure gets around.
Give me a hard copy of that.
Tell me why ain't nothing but I'm...
Oh, I can't zoom in on the other guy?
Harding.
Tell me why...
Ain't nothing but I'm missing.
I never wanna hear you say...
Who's this?
Wait, that's a person!
Wait!
I just...
I didn't know what I was looking at.
Um...
Uh...
Oh, there were some people concerned about me doing karaoke.
Um...
Karaoke for my, uh...
For my anniversary.
But it won't be so long.
And I did get the okay to do so.
So...
Yeah.
It's all good.
Enhance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uploading personal clue database.
The mainframe confirmed what I'd already guessed.
The car from Chinatown was the same vehicle that had smacked the hydrant at Runceters.
The car was registered to a woman named Dektora.
She'd bought it from the used car lot in the fourth sector.
Dektora!
I ran the name two records and came up empty.
The used car lot checked out clean, too.
But maybe the owner could tell me something.
Mm-hmm.
Dektora.
Remove my...
Replicant Inhibitors.
Dektor.
We got a lead, baby.
Oh, here it comes.
Roof...
I don't know why.
This just tickles my fancy.
Roof...
Roof.
We're going to the nightclub, baby.
I've never been to one.
How exciting.
Dektora McFly.
I need to watch Back to the Future 2.
Are you doing any drugs?
I'm a clean girl.
Sexy lighting.
Are we going in there?
Live XXX, girls.
Elevator.
Roof lady's voice reminds me a little of Ryo from Lifeline.
Don't say that.
Did she just say Gongaga?
What's the soundtrack?
I guess we gotta go in.
Whoa!
What are they doing in there?
A little betta fish.
Is there gonna be more inside?
Oh, wow.
I don't remember any of this.
Maybe my dad didn't leave.
For any of this.
She's doing...
Oh no, she's doing the sh...
Oh, she's doing the hurricane twist.
Wow, she's doing the Freddy Krueger.
Whoa!
Oh God, she's doing the bend over Billy.
Oh, spread eagle!
Whip around!
Oh no, it's an advanced technique.
Only those 10 plus years in the abyss would know.
Oh my God, she does it again.
Is that our girl, you think?
Oh shit, I can talk to her.
Sorry, I didn't mean to cry, so I'm just excited.
Who is this guy?
I...
We stick out like...
This place is way more, like, uh...
Alternative than I imagined it would be.
This here is reserved for VIPs.
Oh, this.
But that's my name, Vip.
You're a cute boy, Alex.
This here is reserved for VIPs.
Uh, yeah, that's my name.
He really tried.
Ah, good one, McCoy.
Is this the guy that just told us we couldn't go in?
Hey, Hanoi.
Where's Early?
Off Wolf Fat Farm.
What?
You can do better than that.
No, it's true.
Mr. Q sent me a vid just yesterday.
Getting the hell of a tan he is.
Whoa.
He's not even on this planet.
Am I gonna regret this?
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm just standing there.
Wait.
Do I need to have like a sensor ready?
Oh.
This music's crazy!
Let me tell you what I want.
And maybe I'll impress you.
What?
How old are you?
Haven't I seen you around here before?
Let me tell you what I want.
And maybe I'll impress you.
Oh ho ho ho.
Okay.
How old are you?
I think, okay, okay.
Alright.
He just says the same things over and over again.
Sod off!
You got no appointment, and you got no warrant.
No warrant!
Oh.
Wait.
This is not where I'm supposed to be.
Maybe?
Um...
I'm looking for a...
Wait.
Maybe we distracted him.
Sod off, McCoy.
I've got no time for you.
I'm gonna shoot you.
I've got...
A gun.
Oh, no.
They kicked me out!
Because I...
Did you see that?
I was on the ground!
They kicked me out because I pulled out!
Oh my God!
What?
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Can I get a...
Can I get one at the bar, at least?
The service here sucks!
Please!
Pull out the gun again.
Okay, hold on.
I pull out the gun?
Oh my God!
They actually...
Wow!
I was expecting the subtitles to say...
Speaks British for a second.
Wait!
Is it not Australian accent?
Pull out two guns!
Wait!
Now I'm at a loss!
Hold on.
Let me get back to the...
To the uh...
I was trying to get to the...
Walkthrough where we were at.
Because I feel like we...
Sod off as British.
Oh!
Okay.
Just kidding.
I don't know accents at all.
I'm dead.
Why not?
Oh, oh, oh!
Um, uh, uh, uh, uh...
Oh wait!
There was uh...
The car shop.
That's what it's telling you.
I've got my gun out.
I got my gun out.
That's right.
We had the...
Maybe that's where...
Let's see.
Animal brothers.
Runesitters.
Brad's spirit DNA.
Nightclub.
Oh, Hysteria Hall?
Maybe that?
I don't remember.
I don't remember that.
Going there?
Yes, this is... Oh, there it is.
Used cars.
Okay, cool, cool.
Is this an arcade?
It was the trickster.
He said Pat doesn't have a mink coat.
She's got a good Republican court coat.
That's all.
The trickster.
You're wrong, sweetie.
It was Herbert Hoover.
I'm sorry, but I was there.
If anything, you were all at three years old back then.
I still remember it, like it was yesterday.
And he said fur coat, not mink.
I saw it on the Discovery Club.
Minky!
Are you guys still battling it out?
That's what keeps America alive in kicking day.
What do you mean?
Oh, he knows, Amaga.
What can we do you for?
The works.
Coming right up.
Are we getting hot done?
You know anything about politics, right?
Famous quotes, things like that.
I try not to.
How about the checker speech?
Never heard of it.
Hoover's checker speech.
What?
Nixon's checker speech.
You're forgetting a lot, your old age.
Right behind you, lady.
No way, we just got a hot dog.
Is that... Oh, my bad.
Is that in our inventory?
Toy dog.
Ooh, what a... what a photo.
The car was registered to a woman named Dektora.
She'd bought it from a used car lot in the fourth sector.
I ran the name through records and came up empty.
The used car lot checked out clean, too.
But maybe the owner could tell me something.
It's Nixon.
Of course he doesn't know anything.
Oh, let's go in the arcade.
Hall of mirrors.
Ew.
What's in here?
So much for the toy.
He gave the thank you.
Aw, yeah.
Ew, I don't want to go in the hall of mirrors.
Seems like that's the only thing we can do, though.
Moon bus!
Oh, my gosh.
We found moon bus.
Wait, does it let me go in here?
Oh, that's the exit.
I feel like I'm going to get jumped in the hall of mirrors.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm going to save.
Let's go in.
With my...
With my gun out?
Oh.
This is...
Not what I...
Uh...
What?
I'm so small.
Oh, we're here.
Oh, okay.
I can't run.
I can get my gun out.
What's the object...
Objective?
Mirrors.
Don't go.
This looks more like a...
Like a...
Oh, my gosh.
I keep wanting to say paintball, but that's not what I mean.
Airsoft arena.
Where the hell am I supposed to be going?
Oh, I can run.
Just kidding.
Oh.
I can go really fast.
Apparently.
Go, go, go, go.
Uh.
I thought something was green, but it was me.
What the hell is this?
I can just click and tell them where to go, I guess.
Wait, where am I supposed to be going?
I don't see anything!
Ha!
Who is this?
Reminds me of laser tag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm assuming you don't want to get spotted by the spotlights.
Suddenly Metal Gear.
Can you imagine if Metal Gear played like this?
I...
I'm not sure we need to be here yet or something.
Because there's nothing...
If I go along the edges...
There's...
Oh!
Just kidding.
I think he's going the right way.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's a long...
Oh, there he is.
I saw him for a tiny second.
Oh, there he is!
Okay.
He's running.
Oh, there he goes.
He's going.
Where he's going?
I don't think we know.
Rima, thank you so much for the bread.
La la la la.
Uh, we just did this really awesome...
Hall of Mirrors, I think.
What was that?
And we're going to the...
We're playing Blade Runner.
I forgot to mention.
Rock for Robin, thank you so much for the...
Five Crypto-Dwargo.
Thank you for the five...
It's a killer, I kid you not.
Only $35,000.
Thank you.
Yeah, red, orange, blue, puke green, any color you want.
Not the puke green.
Just give me 24 to hose the graffiti off.
Just kidding.
Ask for the man.
Crazy Legs Larry.
Toodaloo.
Admiring that bishikata, ain't you?
I don't blame you.
It's a classic ride in a deluxe sport package.
Thank you.
It'll push 125 without so much as a shake.
Of course, you've got to find the road for it.
125.
That's always the problem.
Crazy Legs Larry Hirsch.
Pleased to meet you.
Ray McCoy.
You can call me Crazy.
You can call me Larry.
You can even call me Crazy Legs Larry.
But don't call me if you don't think a hot set of wheels ain't necessary.
I love Crazy Legs Larry.
The bishikata is exceptional.
Mechanical is Pacific Rim flawless, as usual.
Pacific Rim.
But they also saved some of the classic styling of the old GM days.
Looks like a piece of work.
Max, happy birthday!
Forget those fibroplast Filipino heaps everyone's driving around.
This is real.
Just feast your eyes on this.
You see it?
That's actual chrome, the real stuff.
They saved a couple hundred sheets of Tijuana chrome from before the war.
It's completely legal and everything.
Beautiful, isn't it?
What happened?
I don't think I've ever seen it before.
And you probably won't ever see it again unless you steal this puppy.
Wow, he's a salesman.
And honestly...
No.
Frankly, I gotta tell you, it's got your name written all over it.
Ray McCovey.
McCoy.
Give or take a couple letters.
I'll have to think about it.
Don't think too long or too hard about it, Roy.
It's liable to be Gonzo by the time you come back.
Gonzo.
Gotcha.
Seeing a lot of running and not enough blades.
I don't even think we have a blade, which is kind of sad.
I'm gonna go peek at your stuff.
I keep your paws off that, Ray.
She's like, come on.
Maybe...
I'm trying to be a hospital here.
Hospitable.
Not a hospital.
Hospitable here.
You can call me crazy.
You can call me Minky.
You can call me crazy-legs Minky.
See if he has anything.
You sell a black sedan a few days ago?
Black sedan?
Hey, I got standards.
If it ain't sporty, I got no room for it.
I've seen the registration.
I know a woman bought it from you.
Oh, that sedan.
Hey, look, a sexy blonde wants to pay top dollar for the ugliest car in the place.
Who am I to say no?
A sexy blonde.
Did you know who she was?
No, but I'd like to know her in the biblical sense if you catch what I'm saying.
Sir?
Look, Ray, it ain't a crime for me to make a living.
Yeah, Ezo's blade.
I hope you get paperwork for all these vehicles.
Are we kids or what, Ray?
You're talking to crazy-legs Larry Hirsch here.
I take that as a yes.
You can take it any way you want.
Just don't take it for a test drive in the fourth sector.
I hope you get paperwork for all these vehicles.
I think...
Okay.
What's upstairs?
Whoa!
Wait a second.
What's this?
Locked.
That sucks.
What?
McCoy is such a hater.
He hates everything.
Locked.
Okay.
Is there anything I'm supposed to be seeing here?
I thought this was, like, some sort of buff, but no.
Mic Mac, thank you!
Oh, whoa.
Hey, Ray, how you doing?
I'm good.
Just fine, crazy.
You've been thinking about the caddy, haven't you?
I don't blame you, she keeps me up at night, too.
It's fine, crazy.
And I ain't ever even lip-wrestled in the back seat, which is definitely what's in the cards for a stud of your caliber.
Throw in a babe and maybe you've got a deal.
Or crazy legs, please!
That's what, I'll have one over in a jiffy.
No, just kidding.
Oh, jeez!
Hold on, I'm gonna... Sorry, I'm consulting the walkthrough again.
Old obtuse game, please understand.
Oh, I missed something at the...
At the hotel, that crime-seam room, apparently.
Oh, or... I don't think I grabbed it.
Consulting.
I don't think I grabbed... Hold on.
Let's see.
Actually, I don't even see the thing that I grabbed in there.
Oh, wait.
Moolag Bas!
That guy sure gets around.
Please issue weapons.
Staggered by punches.
Okay.
Is this the blonde lady?
Clutter registration, China blonde.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Ease all!
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't even realize...
Okay, all?
None?
What?
Oh, gosh.
This is so...
Oh, the UI on this is crazy.
I just want to see all the stuff that I have.
All of it.
Moon Bus.
This is the murder.
You can call her Freaky.
You can call her Menky.
You can even call her Freaky Ghost Menky.
Freaky Ghost Men.
Hope you're having a good Tuesday, Men Dole.
Thank you, my girl.
I'm having the best that I can have.
My ribs still hurt, and at least two teeth were loose.
Sadiq was a tough customer, but he just didn't act like a rep.
I got in at least one good shot.
Thank you so much for the pink defeat.
A Nexus 6 wouldn't have even blinked.
A little database, mate.
Oh, here we go.
Cheese!
Okay, Clovis and Moon Bus.
Stop, I don't want to hear about his Sebastian DNA.
What the hell?
We're just carrying some guy's DNA.
Oh, this is Gordo.
Yeah, yeah, the guy with the crazy...
The crazy outfit.
Holden's badge.
Oh, I think this is what we got at the hotel room.
Hysteria token.
Do we use this at the arcade?
Izo's friend.
Moon Bus.
Ragdoll.
Ew!
I don't like that.
Staggered by points.
So I'm going to go back to that hotel real quick.
Oh yeah, Hysteria Hall.
So what do we use that for?
Did you find the hot dog?
I didn't.
Where was that?
Bradbury.
Ouchie, my ribs hurt.
Ouchie, ouch.
Oh wait, wait, this is the creepy building.
No?
Maybe we kind of look around in it a little bit.
Since I wanted to before.
Yeah?
Wait, what's in here?
The fastest elevator known to man.
We didn't even go in here.
I miss so much, what the heck.
Right.
I don't think I did, at least.
Why are you so loud?
I was chasing one of the perpetrators.
Well, everything's alright now.
I'm pretty sure I can handle it.
You may think you can, but believe me, you can't.
Better if I check it out.
If you insist.
I don't think they took anything.
I don't really have anything here of any value.
You work for Tyrell Corporation?
Yes, sir.
I'm one of the principal design engineers for Dr. Tyrell.
He's a very nice man.
You know, he even fronted me the money to buy this building.
It's a landmark, you know.
You really should see the front edifice.
They put some amazing detail into it.
You feeling alright?
Oh, sure.
I'm fine.
You wouldn't be hiding anybody, would you?
No, sir.
There's nobody here but me and my friends.
What friends?
Evening, general.
See?
I make friends.
He almost looks real.
He's plenty real enough for me.
And real good company, too.
Look, I gotta check the premises again.
Maybe they left something behind.
Thank you.
Well, if you want to take a look, go on ahead.
I can't stop you.
But please be careful in my lab.
He's got a parrot on him?
He's got a little...
It was some kind of freakish toy.
Half mechanical, half organic.
Rep technology for sure.
But no one was going to give me any retirement bonus for it.
Oh.
Now, where did we explore?
I think we went this way.
So let's look this way.
Oh, no.
No, no.
We were in this room.
Oh.
Oh, God.
No.
We definitely came in here.
Oh, I remember.
Wait.
Sorry.
Oh, this is the...
Okay.
Maybe we did go through everything then.
Oh, God.
They're always following me.
Gosh.
They're so creepy.
I'm not even...
I'm not even one to be afraid of dolls or anything.
But...
Golly.
Maybe it's because I was so scared of it as a kid.
Seeing it again is just bringing out all those emotions.
Let's just wait.
Oh, yeah.
We did see this.
What?
Surely there's something here, though.
Okay.
I think I'm just wasting time.
Creepier than a labubu.
Yeah.
I guess we saw everything.
What's over this way?
The lab.
Hmm.
I guess we did see everything.
Yeah.
And his running water room.
And then the ladder that we went up.
And that led to...
This area.
Then...
That we...
Yeah.
Okay.
We can leave them.
I guess we saw everything.
I think they're cute.
What?
The little walking guys?
I think usually...
I would think...
I think...
I think usually I would.
But it's just evoking such a...
Wait a second.
Like an old memory.
For me.
Never mind.
Shut up, monkey.
At least we got to see him.
Because we did not get to see him before.
But how do I get to...
I guess we'll go from...
Uh...
China...
Town.
Man.
Okay.
Take your mask.
And then...
I was like, what was I doing here again?
There was something I missed...
In the...
In the hotel room.
Apparently.
I guess.
It said somewhere in the trash can.
Aha!
That?
It was an animal scale.
Okay, cool.
Well, why did that not show up for me before?
I feel like I've combed that whole room.
Blind...
Blind, minky.
Okay.
I am once again...
Consulting...
The walkthrough.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Okay, that's what I thought.
We have to go back to the arcade.
I don't know what...
This is...
This is GameFAQs.
It is a truly...
A GameFAQs walkthrough moment.
Ah.
Click through.
We do be clicking.
Nowadays, kids only have...
Let's Plays.
Lucy.
You seen a girl around here?
About 14.
With pink hair?
Maybe in the arcade.
I was 14 with pink hair once.
A long time ago.
Don't think he means you.
Yeah, this isn't about you, Mia.
Of course not.
Not now.
We work outside this area hall, don't we?
Well, we must see 20, 30 girls a day with pink hair.
And every other color in the rainbow.
I guess hair dye is really cheap.
You know where I could score some cheese?
Like this stuff?
Boy, don't flash that around here.
He's the police, sweetie.
Besides, the kids today...
Just as soon Trista might be in your backside as to ask Virginia for the tram home.
Show that cheese around here.
You become a marked man.
Why?
Who sells it?
Now, we aren't asking for any trouble, right?
I'm not working, Bunko.
I just want some information.
Dark nutty board.
Who runs Kingston Kitchen.
Kingston Kitchen, you said?
She's always bragging about her special ingredient.
That stew she makes.
It always did taste a little gamey.
And she charges an arm and light for her, too.
The logo, yeah.
I wonder if this one, too.
So we're going to a kitchen?
I feel like a real detective in this game.
Just kidding, we're going nowhere.
I am once again consulting.
Okay.
Sorry.
Sorry for looking at the walkthrough so much.
I just kind of don't want to, like, just be roaming around everywhere, you know?
Let's see.
We're going back to...
Run sitters.
Nope.
Just kidding.
Anemoid Row.
These games are easy to get stuck, y'all.
I know.
They're so fun.
Oh, I wonder if this lady had...
I was wondering what this place was again.
I kind of forgot.
I wonder if she has any info.
Run, run, run.
Running, run.
We gave her.
Any luck finding more of that dragonfly jewelry?
Oh, si, si, I was right.
This you show me was part of the connection.
Blade Runner, not Blade Rover.
Bought for nightclub in fourth second.
Ah!
You know the name of the nightclub owner?
No, senor.
But my friend, he says the man is not selfish.
The nightclub.
Are we going right there?
No, we're going in...
This is...
No.
Hawker?
This is Hawker, yeah.
In here.
Oh, yeah.
We got to ask this lady about the...
We got to ask about the cheese.
Ma'am?
I've got some cheese.
Mia and Murray tell me you're using cheese in your stew.
Real cheese.
Demo buzzards.
What they know?
I could take a sample of that stew you're cooking back to the lab and have a test...
I forgot this place was called Kingston.
Why, you pick on Mama Isabella.
I never do.
You know her.
Yeah.
Where'd you get it?
My sister.
She got connections.
Where can I find her?
She back in Jamaica, man.
Far away from here.
She sent me cheese once, maybe twice a month.
Jamaica's got the cheese.
Funny thing you asking about the cheese.
Last week...
Kevin, happy birthday!
...this ugly little man he run by.
Grab whole box of empty takeout cartons right off the counter.
Not ugly little man.
Police next door.
They just laugh.
Say the guy not be so happy when he opened them cartons.
What's that have to do with the cheese?
Cheese hidden in that box, man.
Keeping it safe till I cook up a new batch.
So how could I tell police to bring back box?
They find cheese, they shut me down.
Why is cheese illegal?
This guy who robbed you, what do you look like?
Shark.
Little shark.
Bad clothes.
Colors way too bright.
Funny bow tie.
Oh, what's his name?
Gordo?
Maybe you look for this...
Oh, shoot.
What about that guy's name?
Yeah?
I'm thinking you not really care about the cheese.
You're right.
But I still think you ought to get yourself a different secret ingredient.
Batman.
That cheese been nothing but trouble for Mama Isabella.
Gordo!
He's our cheese thief, maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Okay, one second.
Sorry.
I tried to do this and it didn't let me...
What the heck?
What the heck is going on?
Remember how at the police station I was like zooming in on the pictures and I was trying to get the people in the background of the moon bus?
But it wouldn't let me.
But now I'll walk through saying zoom in on the people in the background of the moon bus.
That's what I tried.
Maybe I was sequence breaking.
We tried doing it after someone tells her to.
No.
A bracing story about the dark and gritty illegal cheese trade of the future.
Blade Runner versus Cheese Runner.
Maybe Mama Isabella would say it's not so easy, man.
All together now.
It's easy.
Thank you.
This game's non-linear with progression, maybe.
I feel like it's...
I feel like it's been...
Both.
Because it's definitely kind of like a...
You can't do one thing without doing something else kind of situation.
Let's see if this guy has anything to say.
Hello.
You keeping busy, pal?
Nah, the place...
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
You keeping busy, pal?
Let's see if that one is...
Uploading personal clue database.
Downloading mainframe clue database.
Clue database transfer complete.
Why is he so snarky?
He's just got the cop attitude.
Okay, moon bus.
Moon bus.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Wait.
Didn't I try to do this before?
Maybe this guy over here?
You almost got it right.
You just didn't highlight the shadow at the back right of the quadrant.
Are you kidding me?
Is it this one?
That's damn strange.
Give me a hard copy of that.
What is it?
I can't actually tell.
Huh?
It's... Capture.
Trees detecting.
Sending nukes.
Isn't that the Jeopardy sound?
It does sound like it, right?
I'm turning 33 tomorrow.
Could you wish Kenneth a happy birthday?
Kenneth!
Happy birthday!
Oh, next to the truck.
What the hecky?
This guy where?
This one?
The one that I said it was a person before?
Oh!
I... I think I see it.
Th... No.
There's no way it's this.
No, that's just normal shadow.
I thought it was like a person's shadow.
Um...
Nani?
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Am I... dumb?
What is that on the ground?
Is that anything?
Just the ground?
I think it's just the ground.
The answer was Cheese.
Who is Cheese?
Um...
But zoom in on the guy sitting right there.
Now zoom in on Sadiq, the guy on the left.
Yeah.
Finally, way in the shadows by the moon bus, zoom in on...
In the shadows of the moon bus?
Is this...
Is this not the person we're looking for?
Oh...
You're not gonna be able to answer the Daily Double!
What?
It's him?
Then why isn't it telling me?
I keep getting the same thing every time.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I...
It's doing the same thing every time.
Wait!
Oh!
It hits!
That can't be me.
Give me a hard copy of that.
It's us!
That's what they were talking about.
Family, maybe.
Oh my god.
Wait, so we know them.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we gotta go back to the Tyrell building, it seems.
I don't know why we're going back to the Tyrell building.
Oh, I'm hungry!
You don't know why this is gonna happen!
It's...
That's exactly how it looks when I went.
You got an appointment this time?
Nope.
So why are you here?
Wait.
It says we're supposed to have an appointment.
Uh-oh, what did I miss?
Big boss, deep cover ending.
What did I miss?
When am I supposed to get an appointment?
It's so embarrassing when you forget to make the reservations.
I like how he's just like, you have an appointment?
Nope.
What?
Pull my gun?
Let's see what happens.
Hey, I said I don't have an appointment.
Just unload.
Let's go through everything, I guess.
What?
Uh-oh.
Sorry, guys.
I'm screw... I'm a screw-up.
Let me talk to them.
See if I would...
So, anyone else explode around here lately?
I eat any more of that cafeteria food my stomach's liable to.
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave, sir.
You're gonna throw me out?
If need be.
Oh.
What?
I didn't... I didn't talk or anything.
Huh?
How am I supposed to have an appointment?
Hmm.
Interesting.
You can pull out your gun anywhere except the strip club.
They got morals there.
Hahaha.
Did not know this game existed.
It's actually quite fun.
But, you know...
...games of this era are quite obtuse as well.
Hahaha.
How?
Okay, hold on.
McCoy didn't ask security on how to meet Dr. Tyrell.
He won't be able to ask Guzza in requesting an appointment.
Let me go ask Guzza.
Yeah, let's go back to the police station, maybe.
Mr. Mr. Bossman.
Please.
I still can't get over how good this game looks for $19.97.
It looks so good.
Lock up.
This is our man, right?
No!
He's too busy just wandering everywhere.
This guy!
Help, please!
Ah...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe he's wandering around the police station, too.
Maybe we'll just see him come around the corner.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I'm actually stuck.
Because the...
The...
The guide.
I'm only, like, skimming the guide, so...
I probably do miss things, too.
But...
I missed something.
It seems.
I missed something else.
Oh, there he is!
Hey.
Tough day, McCoy.
Oh, come on.
Hey.
You killed anyone yet?
This guy sucks.
Ah, this guy sucks.
Okay.
Well, then we go to the roof.
Okay, I gotta go back...
...to that dang hotel again.
I missed so much there.
Did I kill anyone?
I don't think I did.
Oops, sorry.
I just...
Bonked my mic.
Not yet.
There will be...
Shed!
Okay, this is...
Do you see that?
Right there?
That's what I...
Freaking missed.
Agh!
The wrapper was from a vendor I knew.
Best lycan dogs in the fourth sector.
That wasn't saying a whole lot.
But with an arcade next door and a dozen nightclubs down the street...
Mia and Murray's stand saw more action in a night than my spinster aunt saw all last century.
Damn.
Not the spinster.
Wow, I know, right?
Holy cow.
Here I was, praising.
I was just like, It's so easy to see the things you need to click.
Hahaha.
Last stream I was just like, Dang, everything's outlined.
Back to...
Hysteria Hall.
Oh my gosh, I just noticed the crazy legs.
Hahaha.
He's so committed to the bed.
I found this wrapper.
Yeah, that's from one of our dogs.
No way, that's all you have to say about it.
Hahaha.
Be good, you two.
Huuuuh.
Back to the...
Back to the guidebook.
Hahaha.
Oh, yeah, that cracked the case, everybody.
Golly.
Ah, cereal hall.
I don't know about...
Uh-oh.
Crazy Legs... Let's try it.
Let's try Larry again.
Crazy Legs.
Keep your paws off that, Ray.
Sorry.
I hope you get paperwork for all these vehicles.
Are we kids or what, Ray?
You're talking to Crazy Legs Larry Hirsch here.
Oh, okay.
I take that as a yes.
You can take it any way you want.
Just...
Okay, we heard this.
All right, thank you.
Thank you so much, Strike, for helping.
Thank you!
Okay, let's hope that she's here now.
Maybe in here?
Do I have to chase her through the hall of mirrors?
I sure hope not.
I don't see her here!
No!
Gosh, why does this game hate me?
She's not in the hall of mirrors, is she?
Nobody's in here!
This room sucks!
No!
Oh, no!
Once you're in, you have to go through the whole thing!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
Oh,
my God!
The BPM of the song is doubled!
Oh, my God!
I can't keep up!
Mysterious!
This...
Ah...
Wait...
I missed some...
Okay, there was something I...
Missed at the animoid row.
I remember going there, or...
I think I was supposed to go there and I did not go there.
Because I was silly...
Okay...
Sorry, I completely...
Missed a part of what I was supposed to do, because I...
Thought I had done it, and I didn't.
And I'm like, rah-rah.
You ever sit back and wonder who is...
Who in the universe of these games is building this type of stuff?
Well, that's like a...
Oh, okay, here it says...
Wait, okay, so we did come here, but what was it?
The woman running the fish place.
But she's not here.
Nobody's here.
This... because we have to talk to her about the scale.
Oh, here she is!
Ah!
Go back, go back, go back!
Go back, please.
Is this scale from a fish?
There we go!
Same as other one.
Not fish.
Snake scale.
What other one?
Other police show me scale from same snake.
I send him to Abdul Hassan.
How could you tell I was police?
Both of you walking around look confused.
Like you in wrong place.
The scale is the thing that I forgot.
It was in the bathroom of the, uh...
I think that's the guy with the snakes.
It was in the bathroom of the hotel.
Okay, progress!
Progress, baby.
Is that all I was supposed to do?
We don't talk to the guy...
There was a guy here with a snake, no?
Before?
Curious.
Why...
Why do I feel like I'm so...
...bleh...
...today with...
...figuring out this game?
Okay, but it's saying to go...
Maybe it unlocks the next point so Lucy shows up.
I'll try, but...
...it's not telling me to...
...see Lucy yet.
Let's check.
The woman said McCoy looked confused, so it's lore accurate.
Absolutely.
Lucy!
Lucy, I'm...
Oh!
There she is!
Oh my gosh!
Lucy!
I've been looking for you.
Yeah!
Please, leave me alone.
No, no, please, Lucy.
Father told me to watch out for you.
You don't know what I've been through to see you.
I'm not gonna hurt you.
Have you always lived on Tara?
Yes.
Father told me he thought Tara would be...
...so special and beautiful.
Birds and flowers and trees...
You're like Papa!
...and blue water.
But it's not like that at all.
I don't remember it ever being like that.
Oh wow, we've got a lot to ask her, okay.
Come with me.
I've got a test I want you to take.
No!
Oh my god.
Please!
Go after her!
Holy shit!
I forgot that was the test.
Okay, she'll be back.
She'll be back.
She'll be playing the game again.
Surely.
Okay, I didn't even know this was an exit.
No urgency at all.
Where the hell did she go?
Did you see a girl come through here?
Please say yes!
Please!
Crazy!
Oh my god.
Lucy, don't you want to play your video games?
What did you just say?
Chat, why does Minky look adorable?
What are you talking about?
Oh.
The maze?
I don't think she's in there.
I don't know.
She ran the other way.
I'll look.
But we're gonna have to run through the whole thing again.
Like a mouse to cheese.
It's one of those tests that they give the rats.
To find the cheese.
Yes.
We had so many things to ask her and she ran away.
As soon as we were like...
Come with me.
Gosh, McCoy.
Don't you have any grace or anything?
He has no social skill.
Nazrin.
Maybe...
Maybe running through that resets it.
Let's see.
Maybe that's our torture.
Oh, she's...
She's gone!
I can't believe she's gone!
I can't believe I blew it!
I can't believe I went through so much.
Wait, maybe we'll ask them.
Did you see a girl?
Be good, you two.
We're so stupid.
What do you mean we?
Yes, we!
We're all...
You're...
We're all together in this.
Let me put that negative resets.
I forgot what that thing was.
That it was the test.
I
have my appointment today for sure.
Hello.
Appointment.
I'm a very busy man.
Oh my god.
Okay, you know what I think we should do?
I think we should go home and sleep.
I think we should just go home and take a nap.
I think that will solve all our problems.
I'm gonna tuck you guys in.
I'm tucking you in.
I'm gonna tuck you.
I'm gonna put in the...
I'm gonna...
On the sides, you know, when you push in the blanket.
I'm gonna do that.
So you can't move.
I'm gonna give you...
Mackie, stop!
You're gonna wake the baby!
Then I'm gonna give you...
A little kiss on the forehead.
Mwah!
And then...
I'm gonna play Slipknot.
Wack!
Okay, nap time!
Portrait of the sleep deprived.
That's disturbed.
Oh, you're so right.
Sorry.
I never claimed to be a fan.
Your floor number, please.
Oof.
Okay.
I feel like...
Sleeping to heavy metal would be like...
Sleeping to white noise, no?
I don't see it as any different.
But when I can't sleep...
Sleep?
I can only sleep to, uh...
Like, people talking.
Cause if I...
Sleep...
If I leave myself with my own thoughts, I won't be able to sleep.
So I have to have someone talking...
So that I don't listen to myself.
Oh my gosh, it's really gone!
When did I last save?
Okay, but I think this was a while ago.
I think we've done many things since this...
Guys, I'm...
I'm like legitimately lost right now.
Because...
Let me tell you what the walkthrough tells me to do.
Act 3.
We start at the hotel.
And then we go to the lobby in the crime scene.
Then we go to...
Um...
Hysteria Hall here.
Then we ask about the...
We talk to the old people.
Then we go to the used car shop.
Then we go to the animoid row.
And we talk about...
The...
The fish?
Oh, actually...
I wonder if the fish needs to be in the system.
Maybe.
Then we talk to cheat...
To...
To the lady at the restaurant about the cheese.
Then we go to the police station.
And then we go to Tyrell headquarters.
That's what...
The...
The guide is telling me.
So that's why I'm so confused!
That's why I'm so confused!
Baby car, thank you for the gift.
Thank you!
So that's why...
It's very confusing for me.
Hmm...
Unless...
Maybe this tutorial is wrong?
I don't know...
Let's go back...
And...
Um...
I think we have different guides.
Oh, do we?
Maybe...
We should go to the other club.
The...
The strip club?
Mainframe...
And shooting range.
I like the way she says that.
Uploading...
Personal clue database.
Downloading...
Mainframe clue database.
Maybe we needed to...
Upload stuff about the fish.
Clue database transfer complete.
Try talking to the lab guy.
Yeah, that's true.
Let's try talking to him.
He was floor...
Nope.
He's not even here!
What a slacker.
Will you be coming to Animethon?
Asakasa?
Will be there?
Asaka?
Unfortunately, no!
I won't be, but...
Have fun!
Her...
Shows are so much fun.
I've seen her a couple times live now.
You know what?
Let's just go to the strip club.
When in doubt...
Go to the strip club.
Get your guns out.
Go, go, go!
Woo!
They won't kick me out if I run in with my gun.
See?
It worked.
Maybe we can go in here now.
Sod off, McCoy.
I've got no time for you.
I don't...
I lost!
Please, sir!
Early's waiting on me.
Sod off!
You've got no appointment, and you've got no warrant.
Wait, but I know his name!
Lady?
Not the talkative type.
Please!
Haven't I seen you around here before?
That's such a creepy line.
Don't say that.
I'm a VIP!
I am a VIP!
Wait, how did I get in here?
Ah!
Uh-oh.
How did I get in here?
Wait.
Whoa, she just did...
Do the wave!
Whoa, what are you...
Whoa!
Oh my god!
She's so flexible!
Is this doing it for you guys?
I can't...
Wait, is she the blonde lady that we're needing to talk to?
This is such a dance.
Yeah, throw your ones, everybody!
Wiggly arms must be...
I like how the arms are just up when she's in like, waiting mode.
I can't get over them!
Ha ha ha ha!
Woo!
Oh my gosh!
Ha ha ha ha!
Getting ideas for your next 3D?
No.
How low can you go?
That's a good time.
What's your name?
Why are we such a creep?
Oh, here we go.
What's your pleasure, sir?
The highest octane.
One Venus high trap.
Coming up!
Thank you!
What's the green?
Neptune's nip.
I think you'll enjoy it, sir.
Neptune's...
I like my woman dancing on 5th PS.
Hit me again.
You pick the color.
Ah, 2 at 10, 10 at 2.
Why is it called that?
Let's just say, it's a love potion.
Ooh la la!
Hit me again.
You pick the color.
Ah, 2 at 10?
Okay.
Uh...
What am I supposed to do here?
I made it into the VIP room and I have no idea why.
Can I talk to her?
What's your name?
Why are we so weird?
Wait, can we...
Oh shit!
We're on the floor!
Do a dance McCoy!
Wait, can I also get on the floor?
Oh, I gotta put my arms up.
And then put them down.
Did I do anything for you guys?
I'm sorry.
I'm here to please.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Um...
Oh, this is so sad.
Wait.
Is there something over here?
No.
What are we supposed to do?
Oh.
Wait, what?
I didn't take my gun out at all!
Mister!
Blade Runner is a time capsule of the past future.
What was sexy in 2019?
Dancing Ghost.
What's there?
There's another...
There's another nightclub!
Oh my gosh.
I
got so distracted by the betta fish ladies.
Oh no way!
There's Gordo!
Hey man.
You're that cat from Howie Lee's.
McCoy, right?
We keep bumping into each other.
You want an autograph?
I know you ain't heard of me yet.
But Gordo Frizz's autograph's gonna be worth a pile of chin-yan someday.
Relax.
I'll hold my breath.
I'm gonna ask you a few questions.
Man, don't you got anything better to do than hassle innocent people at their place of work?
Make it snappy, okay?
You're like the most awkward stripper ever?
I really appreciate your patience.
Sorry.
Okay.
The cheese!
Okay, well how's the cheese last since that's the most sensitive information?
You know the chef at Howie's?
That big flabby guy?
Never seen him before.
You were hanging around right when he took off.
Pure coincidence.
You are one hell of a suspicious cat, Nikoi.
Kick back.
Relax.
Watch my show.
Take a little break from your boring existence.
Oh, is he also gonna get on the stage?
Wait, I kinda... wait, what else is...
Uh-oh.
Wait.
No, no, no, I'm not done with you.
Oh, gosh.
Uh-oh.
Uh...
You might wanna blur the poster.
Oh, I think it's okay.
It's okay, sweetie.
Hey, is everybody having a good time tonight?
Thank you, though.
Yeah!
Woo!
Uh-huh.
What does a marriage and a tornado have in common?
First, there's a lot of sucking and blowing, and then you lose your house.
You know what my first wife's nickname was?
Twister.
The doctor calls up his patient.
I got bad news, and I got worse news.
The bad news is, he only got 24 hours to live.
The patient says, what could be worse than that?
The doctor says, I've been trying to reach you since yesterday.
Guess what happens to a rep who does his job really well?
Early retirement, baby.
I see we got a celebrity in the audience.
Can I get a spot, please?
That's right.
It's one of the boys from the local Blade Runner unit.
One of the LPD's finest, Ray McCoy.
Let's give a big hand for Rep Detect McCoy.
He's protecting us poor slobs, ladies and gentlemen.
He even thinks you're a replicant.
He can waste you right where you stand.
Nice job, eh, detective?
It doesn't quite work that way.
How about yourself?
You sure about yourself?
Cause I got some friends, they say they know you.
You're lying.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I think we're on pursuit.
Uh...
Can I go?
Hello?
Someone's calling me?
Damn.
Why does everyone run?
Hello?
Can I look at the poster?
No?
I only got to ask him one thing.
I kind of like his comedy.
He's kind of obsessed with like, twisters and...
Okay.
Everybody hates us.
Oh, there he is.
Hey!
Woo!
Are you shooting at me?
Hey, you can't do that.
They're gonna kick you out of there if you bring your gun out.
I have more questions for you, Gordo!
He's probably in here.
I imagine.
Why do I keep getting kicked out of the strip club?
You suck!
Please!
Early's waiting on me.
Sod off!
You've got no appointment, and you've got no warrant.
Please let me in!
Won't let me in!
What the?!
Let him turn his back?
Oh, okay.
Is that how I snuck in before, I guess?
I feel like his back has been turned!
Let me try here.
Oh, he looks at me.
Okay, let me...
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Ow!
Dang it!
He's fast.
I'm faster.
No!
I'm not faster.
You
know why they kick you out?
You're too freaky for the club.
Here we go.
Nice and easy.
Ow!
Turn away, mister.
I'm not a bother to you.
There we go.
Big ham!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, he's not going to turn around, is he?
Go, go.
Hint is girl on stage?
Okay, let's go talk to her.
Let me tell you what I want, and maybe I'll impress you.
Is he gonna go watch her?
Okay.
Yes, sir!
Nice distraction, ma'am.
There he is!
Gordo!
You shot at me.
Okay, they don't kick me out.
Can you imagine?
He's trying to pretend to be a bartender.
Oh, that's early!
Who are you?
Your man gave me a hard time out there.
Wait, okay.
I like Hanoi, but I can't deny...
I thought you were Gordo.
What's on tap tonight?
Classy shows all evening, General.
You're gonna be able to cut diamonds down there.
Oh, you're money back.
Ooh.
Okay, but where's our guy?
You buy some jewelry at an auction recently?
Real old, elite stuff.
Who's asking?
Me!
You ain't with robbery homicide.
Those pieces ain't hot.
I got the papers to prove it.
I picked them up at legitimate auction.
Cost me nearly a pound of flesh, too.
You give this stuff to a girlfriend early?
No kidding?
I ain't that stupid.
No, no, no, no.
I was letting one of my dancers use this stuff in her act.
Kind of a tribute to the ancient Swamp Man.
You know what I mean?
Ah.
Which dancer?
Heck you, huh?
She's gone, huh?
Heck you, boss.
She's one of my biggest earners, too.
She ain't in any trouble now, is she?
Hmm.
Not yet.
Good.
Wouldn't want to slaughter the goose that lays in the golden age.
The ceiling!
Oh my god!
It's just so...
Okay, they're not naked, though.
No!
Holy!
Holy cow!
I'm working right now, General.
Pass me later.
Okay, sorry.
I'll wait for your girl, Hecuba.
I'm not gonna get kicked out, alright?
Please.
Please, sir.
Okay.
Ma'am?
I'm gonna try this door, too.
Not the talkative type.
No.
She's too cool for that.
Uh...
He turned as soon as I...
Okay, never mind.
Sorry, sir.
Just kidding.
Where's our...
Where's your girl?
No.
It happens to be the name of the antagonist necromancer from Westwood's later game, Nox.
Oh...
Uh...
Okay...
Well, we're here.
Uh...
I hear Gongaga now, right?
I can't...
I can't unhear it.
Every time it, like, loops in that part, I hear Gongaga.
Me?
Gongaga?
Uh...
I wanna go to Sticky.
I'm still very confused about things.
Are...
Hecuba's coming out now?
Yeah, that guy's gone, right?
I have no idea.
Not the talkative type.
We're gonna chill in this room while, uh...
While we figure it out... Down?
What do you mean down?
The purple pants guy?
No, no.
That's a different guy and then this guy is not clickable.
Hold on.
I'm gonna check a different walkthrough since clearly mine is... Okay, here we go.
Tongue Club?
Is that what it's called?
Crazy.
Okay, we're gonna also have to go back to the arcade for Lucy.
It seems.
Okay.
Oh, he had a lighter on the bar.
Okay, we gotta go back.
The Gordo, before he ran out.
I didn't even see.
The countertop in the dark part of the early Q club has bones in it?
Where?
Alright!
Oh my gosh!
You guys see that?
The bones in here?
Under the countertop?
That's crazy!
Whoa!
Hold on, I'm gonna... I sped run getting kicked out so that...
Oh, maybe he is down here!
I thought this was to my car.
Wait, I think it is to my car.
It is.
But he left his lighter in here, apparently.
Pull out gun to get out of the club faster than why.
I'm a true speedrunner.
He apparently... Oh, there... Do you guys see that?
This is what Gordo left on the... Oh my god!
That's the thing you're supposed to notice and pick up.
Incredible work!
Incredible!
Damn!
Wait, it says we're supposed to shoot him.
Or not shoot him, but like...
Maybe he'll be out here again.
It says when you go outside, Gordo is standing there and says something.
But he didn't say anything to us.
He just shot.
And then ran away.
Oh, the walkthroughs are so confusing as well.
What does it say after that?
It says...
Um...
You don't think he's a replicant, but he's a sympathizer.
And you're given a choice of whether or not to arrest him.
You are automatically taken to the police station.
What?
That didn't happen at all!
None of that happened!
Sorry, I keep hovering over this because the blue is making it look like something to click on.
You know, like with this.
So it's distracting me.
What the...
This is so weird.
Maybe we were supposed to shoot him.
Maybe.
But now, I'm stuck again.
Let's...
Maybe go...
Back to...
The arcade.
Gordo can either be a replicant or a sympathizer.
So I guess maybe in this he's a replicant?
Because he shot at us.
If he were a sympathizer...
We would...
Arrest him.
Can you walk down in the club?
It doesn't seem like it.
Oh my gosh, he's still not back.
This is so bad.
The whole...
Guys, the...
The run is ruined.
Get in the car, McCoy!
Get in the car!
Can you go down in the club though?
I picked a different walkthrough.
Wait a second.
Uh...
Give me a second to check something real quick.
I think I had a meeting tonight.
I do.
Oh no, in like an hour.
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to beat it today!
Ah!
At this rate!
Aw man.
I didn't think I would get so stuck all the time.
Like I feel like I've just been running in circles this entire...
This entire stream!
What the heck?
In an hour or an hour ago?
In one hour, yeah.
I'm just like...
Huh?
Every time!
Oh yeah, these games can get like that.
No.
Uh...
Well, I hope you guys are at least having fun.
Even though we're literally going in circles.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, wah-oh, wah-oh.
Oh, wah-oh.
Wah-oh, wah-oh.
Ha-ha!
Wah-oh.
Maybe there's more...
Stuff in the photos that I didn't...
Was supposed to collect.
It...
Maybe seems that way.
But I don't even...
Hmm...
In circles like the strip lady on the rotating platform.
Yeah...
Play me like a...
Damn fiddle!
Hmm...
Gonna go to the strip club.
I mean in the tutorial.
Sorry.
I'm always thinking about that place.
Maybe I have a problem.
It's saying that he's supposed to ask about being a...
Oh, if...
Eh?
What?
Wait, okay, hold on.
Come here.
Gordo's lighter.
Lightning squad.
Rep unit.
Battle of the Gemini.
If Gordo's lighter is painted silver...
He's a replicant who was a member.
Oh!
So he is a replicant.
It seems.
I see.
There are two things that may happen to Gordo depending on the game after coming out of the club.
Gordo will approach and shoots McCoy if he's unarmed.
He'll run into early Q's club and never to be seen anymore.
That's...
That's what happened to us.
I don't think you could not make a...
Wait.
I don't think you could make a not fun stream even if you try.
In fact, I think trying would make it even better somehow.
Okay.
Then I am going to try.
Hmm.
What if I only spoke backwards the whole time?
Yeah.
How do I laugh backwards?
How do I
laugh backwards?
Okay, early Q's.
I'm pretty sure that's speaking in tongues.
No.
Yeah!
Hey, pretty ghost, why don't you try hitting that sexy toggle?
I actually don't know what the sexy toggle is.
I don't think it's naked.
I'm actually not quite sure.
Night... yeah, nightclub.
Let's see.
Try here again.
Okay,
let's see if we can get back in here or something again.
Hello?
Mister?
You're not gonna follow me?
Okay, here we go.
Now he's suspicious.
Okay, now he's suspicious.
Now we walk.
Just kidding, sir?
I don't know.
You know what, let's go try...
Let's try going back...
Though I feel like it would give us a prompt if we actually had a...
A, uh...
What's the word?
A appointment at Tyrell, you know?
Like it would say, now you have an appointment!
Save the money!
And there's nothing else in here?
Really?
Nothing?
What do you think?
What's mean?
Ooh...
I love this green lady statue.
Woo!
Ooh, who's slurping on our soup?
Okay, I don't think there's anything in here.
I think they are drinking from the green lady.
This doesn't seem anything else.
Ugh!
What can I try?
We don't have Lucy!
We don't have...
I'm just gonna go take a nap.
Hard reset, you know?
What if we're a replicant?
But our dog is real.
What if our dog...
We also love the green...
last on screen.
What green...
Hello, Maggie!
Maggie, come here, girl.
I'm gonna pretend that I'm uploading anything...
and doing anything with this stinking thing.
It also mentions some other stuff...
maybe that I missed in here.
Like, uh...
this apparently, I think?
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Deh, deh, deh, deh, deh, euh, uh, ah, hee, Minute, ahh, hee,YU, uh, hee.
Yeah!
See!
Aha!
A strange scale.
That's the scale that Give me a hard copy of that.
That's the scale, we...
Oh!
Spot a familiar face- a unicorn sighting?
What?
No, no, this is a scale.
Is that...
Us?
From behind?
It looks like...
Origami unicorn?
Yeah!
What if you're a replicant and Maggie's an undercover Blade Runner?
I think that's us, no?
I gotta watch the movie now.
There was one other thing I feel like it mentioned to look at in here, but I can't remember what...
What the heck is this?
Banana peel on the ground?
It's a banana peel!
Ugh, might be Deckard.
Oh, true, true, true!
Because he came and asked about it too, right?
All detectives look the same.
I'm sorry for stereotyping, but you all got them coats.
I think there was one other thing in here too, potentially.
This is our girl, no?
This is the one we're trying to see at the club.
Ma'am, please!
Why won't you meet me?
Nah, we're gonna get real specific here.
Enhance the woman.
Yeah, it's the Columbo overcoat.
I don't remember what else it told me to...
What the walkthrough told me to look up.
Nap time!
Portrait of the sleep-deprived.
Just one more thing.
Okie dokie.
Maybe we go on our balcony and wistfully think about what to do next.
Okay.
It's your birthday, someone gives you a calfskin wallet?
Are you sure it's not made out of babies?
Your floor number, please.
Okay.
Oof.
Leather, baby.
Calfs are babies.
Oh my gosh, wait, you're right.
You know what this stream is lacking?
A whole lot of shooting and killing people.
You could change that.
Let's see if Lucy came back.
Lucy, are you home?
I don't think she's ever coming back, guys.
Why is it like we're dressed up?
Alright, let's try the nightclub again.
I'm truly at a loss.
Aww.
Let me tell you what I want.
And maybe I'll impress you.
The guide says to talk to and follow Early Q to Dektora.
The club is called Early Q.
That's where we're at.
Lost in the store, thank you so much for the 10 gift and thank you!
This is my gameplay when my parents enter my room.
Yeah, I guess we'll just sit in the VIP area.
I've talked to him before, this guy.
He said she would come out.
She never did.
Let's get another drink.
Hit me again.
You pick the color.
Ah, 2 of 10, 10 of 2.
Why is it called that?
Let's just say, it's a love potion.
Maybe this is her and we just need to talk- What's your name?
Nope, never mind.
What's your name?
Why does he say it like that?
Hey, Early.
I'm working right now, General.
Oh, his name's Early Q.
Yeah.
Um, hello?
What's your name?
It's like he's talking to a little kid.
I know.
That's why I don't like it.
I guess we'll just stand here.
I hope nobody has a problem.
Just, you know, if you're- Oh, my God.
Ladies and gentlemen, yours truly the ever-ebelliant Early Q presents the wondrous, mysterious...
Hecuba!
Singing and performing the sacred Thanatos dance of the ancient swamps!
Wow.
It finally happened.
Early was like...
Are we just supposed to interrupt her dance?
Look, but don't touch.
I didn't- I didn't think it would be touching her!
Holy cow.
Not the talkative type.
Oh, my God.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Not the talkative type.
Okay, we can run.
Thank goodness.
It's okay.
We can probably just go right back in.
We probably don't have to wait.
Probably.
This place is way bigger on the inside.
Oh, she's gone!
Ma'am?
I missed the whole show.
Wait, but so was that guy.
There was a guy guarding this area.
Look at the lip.
Oh!
What happened here?
We know it's not hard not to be handsy.
How did you reach all the way up there?
He was like jumping.
What's going on here?
This doesn't look good.
This actually looks...
The opposite of good.
I think this looks...
Bad.
Uh...
Oh, there's a ladder.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Before you do that...
We are saving the game.
Okay, there we go.
I feel like every time there's a ladder, there's a shoot-off.
There we go.
I wanna go back to the strip club.
Anything here?
That looks like blood.
Uh...
Anything here?
Literally...
Literally anything!
Oh, wait.
Green.
Come here.
They're watching a sage play.
A banquet is in progress.
The guests are enjoying an appetizer of raw oysters.
The entree consists of boiled dog.
Ew, what?
It's the only thing that is showing up green.
Mister?
Besides yourself.
Am I missing something?
Window?
No?
Green in the middle.
I think it was hovering over him.
All I see is this, but I have no idea.
Says you should be talking to Dektora now.
This game hates me!
Maybe there's somewhere and something else downstairs.
No way!
Is it because I got kicked out?
I didn't know!
Is there anything around here?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, thank goodness.
Okay, we can go to the left.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh my goodness!
Oh, we're backstage!
Holy...
Wow, I thought some ladies would be, you know, getting...
ready in here.
Hmm...
That's strange.
I didn't hear a knock.
I just wanted to say...
I didn't see a door.
Wow!
You were awe-inspiring!
Well, thank you very much, Mr...
McCoy.
Uh, Ray McCoy.
Is there something I can do for you, Mr. McCoy?
Wow!
You were amazing!
At the strip club.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
I can't get over this guy!
Oh, goodness.
Oh wow, the sewing machine and everything.
Um...
Belt?
That's such an unusual belt, is it antique?
They say it's from the last century.
Those little creatures have always been my favorites.
Yeah, looks like...
Dragonflies?
Yes.
And the whole class that contains them.
Tell you the truth, I'm from the LPD.
I'd like to ask you a few questions if I could.
Is this about early Q?
Because I could tell you.
Did any other pieces come with the belt?
I'm sure I don't know what you mean.
So he was just role-playing a nerd to talk to her?
Okay, don't!
You know what?
Oh, ah, ah!
Sorry, I keep clicking that.
Hold on.
Save?
Alright, resume.
Alright.
We're not gonna fumble this time, guys.
Look, I wanna warn you.
There's a woman looking for you and your friends.
Why would anyone be looking for me?
You know what I'm talking about.
It's real important that you get out of here.
I get it.
You're some kind of sexual deviant.
I'm finished with you.
Give me the police.
You're doing the right thing.
I am the police!
Yes, this is an emergency.
Early Q's backstage.
A customer is harassing me.
Thank you.
Put that away!
I'm a cop!
May we wait?
If your hand moves, I'll shoot.
Okay.
Please don't talk.
The sound of your voice grates on my nerves.
We waited there for a few minutes.
Her gun in her eyes never wavered.
Any other mark, I'd have been a dead man.
But if she was a replicant, she must not have known it if she was willing to call the police.
That's true.
Hello, sir!
Oh, she lets us walk towards the police?
This a troublemaker?
Put your hands on top of your head.
I got a badge!
That's right.
Ray McCoy.
Ref Detect.
VR61661.
Never heard of you.
I report to Lieutenant Guza.
Call him.
I work for you.
Let's go.
Where's your squad car?
Yeah, I don't think this guy's a...
Shut your mouth.
I don't think this guy's a cop!
Which precinct are we going to?
I'll tell you which one.
Now.
Tell me.
Oh!
We got a little...
We got a little flash.
This was no precinct house I'd ever been in.
And I thought I'd been in them all.
The grunt to my right had the beefy harness bowl look down pat.
And his twitchy partner in the suit looked like he was just itching to chainsaw a couple of kneecaps.
Hmm.
Other than that, everything was hunky-dory.
Hunky-dory!
Impersonating a police officer, huh?
I guess the new Nexus models are a little more creative than the old ones.
I'm a Blade Runner.
You don't believe me?
Call Lieutenant Guza.
There ain't no Guza in the LPD.
Unless I've been walking around in a dream, there is.
That's what always bugs me.
Yeah, the fact that these skin jobs always gotta live someone else's life.
No shit.
Huh?
Just make the call, dammit!
Hoo!
You're just a piece of shit wrapped with memory implants of this Guza guy.
You understand?
That's... impossible.
Is that why he's been everywhere?
Rep Bane sounded so creative now.
You wanna Void Conf me?
Be my guest.
Very good.
Very convincing.
Where you been hiding?
The Kipple?
Gregorian bring you in?
Who else is working that side of the pool these days?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Ah!
What about that bastard selling all that stuff downtown?
Shut your trap.
I'll tell you something, McCoy.
I don't even care how you go out.
But I know you can feel pain.
And on that account, I'm your man, Si.
You tell me about everyone you met through cars, and I'll guarantee you we'll go real easy.
Please.
Your breath smells like you wiped your ass with your teeth.
Haha.
Damn.
You're gonna wish you was neck deep in an off-world reactor vessel by the time I get through with you.
Fire up the chair, Holly.
His name's Holly?
It looks like Holloway.
You know what I'm gonna come back as?
In my next life.
A priest.
There's something holy about how good I am at this.
Oh no, he's a weirdo.
Oh.
Woah!
Please!
Don't even go for it!
Bang!
Woah!
I don't think that's how that works, ma'am!
You shot...
You got any idea how glad I am to see ya?
Holly!
No time for chit-chat, Slim.
You wanna save your ass, I gotta blow this joint right now.
And STP, thank you so much!
Oh wait, not so Deadpool!
Thank you so much for the five gift in!
Yes!
Ah, loud, loud!
Oh, we're back!
Oh, gosh!
Okay, save.
Woo!
I feel like there's so much in the tutorial that...
Not tutorial, sorry.
The walkthrough that, like...
We never did, but...
Okay!
Where are we?
I only have a little bit more that I can play, guys.
Sorry.
Dang, I really thought I would be able to beat it today.
Sorry that it was so much of just me wandering around, wondering what to do.
This lady is an extremely good shot.
Is that not a little...
What the hell took you so long?
Suspicious.
Maybe she's...
A robot aim.
Good thing you made your entrance when you did.
Good thing one of my snitches saw them escort you out of the club.
Otherwise, you'd be three quarters in the bag right now.
They must have been phony cops, hired by the reps for protection.
Cops?
Yes.
Phony?
No.
Yeah, aimbot.
I remembered Baker.
He used to be an S.I.D.
expert on coercive technique until he was fired from the force a couple years ago.
A mercenary?
Bingo.
He won't have to worry about getting paid no more.
Let's strip her you interviewed.
Sorry, I missed it.
She's one of them.
Figure it out.
She must have made the call to Baker and that other bozo.
Let's attend to some business.
I'm here.
Ah, yeah.
Nice crowd.
Regular folks steal, just like you and me.
Speak for yourself.
You see it anywhere?
I saw someone walk upstairs.
You sure she's in here?
Better look backstage.
Yeah, yeah.
Check the balcony and cover the exit.
Okay.
I want this one giving us the blow off.
So if she goes that way, I go this way?
I saw someone go upstairs, I did.
I did save.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh.
That was...
That was so freaky.
Oh my gosh.
I thought she was gonna shoot me.
I would have died there for sure.
Oh.
She's...
She's floating.
Oh, I'm supposed to shoot her.
Sorry.
My bad.
I thought she was dying.
She was...
She was coming at me!
Been pretty busy, haven't you, Slim?
I think we can safely say that one's in vile mechanical purgatory.
You had to clear out everything else up here, too.
Hope Early's got insurance.
Putz employs replicants.
He oughta expect the worst.
Oh, sorry I missed all the laughs.
Next time.
No, ma'am.
It's around here somewhere.
I'm still laughing.
Where'd you park it?
I'm telling you, it was right here.
Damn thing must have been stolen.
No way!
Our car got...
Maybe you're living in an alternate reality, Slim.
Our car got stolen.
Attention all units.
All points bulletin has been issued for Ray McCoy, formerly BR-61661.
No!
Affirm one civilian kill.
Ezo.
Considered armed and dangerous.
What the hell is that?
We didn't kill Ezo.
Maybe they just wanna bring you in for questioning.
I didn't kill Ezo.
Maybe they think you're not what you think you are.
Are you saying I'm a rep?
Come off it.
The look on your face after that last one.
The minute you start to feel something for skin jobs, you're in big trouble.
Maybe I just got too much empathy.
In all the wrong places.
You wanna put me on the machine?
Hey, I don't want anything, Slim.
You're the one they want.
Detective Steel, BR-61354.
Report to headquarters immediately.
Code blue.
What are you gonna do?
Take me in?
Arrest me?
No matter what they say, you're not on my list yet, Slim.
You know what that means.
And there's no use juicing you if I can't make some honest chinyon off it, you know?
He's an empath.
Oh my god.
He must have messed up somehow.
I'll check it out, see what's going on.
And then...
We'll be meeting again, Slim.
You can bank on it.
Thanks for saving my ass.
I get cracking before I change my mind.
What do I do?
I have to run there?
Oh, I really am.
Just run into the police station.
Where are you going?
Oh!
Reach Act 4.
Yippee!
Is this the twins?
Yeah!
Your old fogey stuff makes me want to spew.
Excuse me, but I was listening to music.
Geek!
Hoodlum!
Dork!
Freak!
There is someone at the door.
Speak!
I have a return package from Mr. Luther Lance.
Uh-oh.
A return?
From where?
Emile Bunsiter.
Uh-oh.
Maybe one of the chimps blew a gasket and tried to bugger him.
They're not available.
Come back later.
Q and Doki.
I told you those strains were unstable.
Runciter must have discovered the fakes.
Relax.
Runciter is a simp.
Not even old man Tyrell could have spotted those beauties.
Why did it put Simpleton?
What is...
Wait!
Is that what simp stands for?
What?
Who the piss do you think you are blasting in here like a couple of goddamn cowboys?
Urgh!
Take a moment to evaluate the situation.
Look.
There's very little to steal here.
If you can haul out one of the statues, be our guest.
We look like thieves to you, Ma?
No.
Uh, no.
You look like a couple of goddamn...
Switching between classical music and Target from CNC.
Take a good, long look.
Yeah?
What are we looking at?
Uh-huh.
Just the people we were hoping to see, right Lance?
Huh?
Nexus 6.
And you came to us.
Return to you, my brothers.
My brothers.
To ask your help.
Unfortunately, we don't work for the Tyrell Corporation anymore.
You've been continuing your research, I trust?
Yeah, of course.
Something drives us on.
The common bond.
Can you have greater miracles than these?
Brothers, my brothers.
Take a good, long look.
Huh?
Oh.
My.
God.
Well, now.
Shall we begin?
What?
You wake up one day and find it's all been a dream.
Or you wake up and discover you've been asleep all the time and the nightmare is real.
What?
I didn't know what it was.
I didn't know who I was.
A cop dangling on the short end of the stick?
Or a rep whose memory banks had run out.
I thought they were gonna kiss too.
One thing I was sure of was that I didn't kill Izo.
That I know I experienced.
And this misinformation, maybe it was the key to everything that was happening.
Maybe there was a lot more than what met my eye.
All I had to do was stay alive long enough to find out.
Someone got a bad hot dog, apparently.
Oh no!
We've hit my max!
Well, hopefully, uh, we don't, um, have any soft walks.
Final cut is recommended for the movie.
It's the director's favorite.
The theatrical version has a different tone.
Oh.
I don't remember which one I watched originally.
So we're trying to get to the police station.
I'm wondering if I should...
Quit around here.
Uh...
This way, I guess.
Just running down the train track.
Whoa!
Guess we just keep going.
Or...
Oh my god!
That's the biggest rat I've ever seen!
Holy cow!
That thing was hopping away!
Did you see that?
Wait, I want it to come back!
Where'd it go?
I want another one.
That thing was...
That looked like a...
A dog.
That looked like a chihuahua.
Me...
Not even...
No, that looked like...
That looked like a terrier.
It was huge!
Okay.
Let's go in here.
It's been nine months.
Thank you so much!
You know what?
Let's just keep going down the hole.
The tunnel stretched for miles.
I was sure it came out somewhere.
But I didn't have time to find out.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Well, let's...
Leave here then.
Okay.
A little freaky in here.
Where are we?
Also, let's start saving down here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hello?
Can I borrow this car?
I hope you get paperwork for all these vehicles.
Okay.
I take that...
You can take it any way you want.
Never mind.
Okay.
I guess we're running.
Wait.
They're not here anymore.
Do you think Lucy came back finally?
Lucy, we made progress.
Please be here.
Okay.
Never mind.
You know what?
Let's go...
What is he gonna do if we borrow a car?
Or...
No.
He won't notice.
Probably.
Let's borrow...
Wait.
This one's locked.
That sucks.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
He just didn't like this one.
Locked.
What about this one?
Well, you're gonna just have to take the ugly car.
I don't know what to tell you.
That sucks.
I just...
I don't know what to tell you.
Sorry.
Beggars can't be choosers, Mr. McCoy.
You're just gonna have to take the ugly car.
That sucks.
It's...
It's Elliot.
Wait.
I keep your paws off that, right?
I...
I gotta get a car.
Flying Dodge Viper.
No way that would suck.
I don't even know what the heck.
They even left the...
The grill going.
Maybe somebody's in here.
Alright.
Sorry, guys.
It's time to go back through the...
The maze of mirrors.
The very...
Maybe that's why nobody is in here.
Because it...
It's bad.
It's...
I got...
I got bamboozled again.
I thought...
Surely...
Third time's the charm.
And runnin' we go.
Runnin' till
we're almost there.
I'm not quite sure...
Where...
What they want us to do.
Cause now we're very like...
There's only so much we can do.
So I think it's time to steal a car.
So we can get back to the police station.
DNA Row.
I can't...
I can't go anywhere.
Like I can't travel the map.
Locked.
Because I don't have a car.
Maybe...
Let me go talk to him again.
I hope you get paperwork for all these...
I take...
You can take it anyway.
Back to the sewers.
But there was no other...
Well...
Maybe I missed it.
I've known for being a little bit blind.
Unnecessarily...
Long stairs.
So we can't go down here.
Oh!
We're running!
Did you see that thing?
I can't go this way.
This leads to the...
Strip club.
Where the thing was...
The thing came running at me!
Nashed.
Oh, wait.
This is not the strip club.
I'm a liar.
I'd seen chairs like this one before.
And not just in my recurring dental nightmares.
It was an old-time LPD soothsayer.
A torture device used to elicit confessions out of hardened criminals.
Its use had been banned for 10 years now.
But most cops knew it hadn't totally disappeared off the face of the earth.
What's in here?
Oh no!
Kidding!
We're back in the...
We're back in the sewers!
No way!
The lever!
We're here!
Wait, can I go this way?
Oh, I can!
I can!
Ah!
Oh, leave!
Time to go.
No...
No hurry...
No sense of urgency at all.
Nope, that's not what I wanted to do.
No.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Oh wait, this does lead somewhere.
Okay...
I can't remember where this came out from.
Like this side.
Big rat.
Grab it, grab it, grab it!
I can shoot it!
No, no, I wanna grab it.
No, I don't.
Oh, oh!
I know where we are!
Okay, this is Izo's...
Izo's lair.
Yes, yes, yes!
So if we got...
Went upstairs...
Okay, we're trying to make it to...
Oh, I thought that was the police talking to me.
Alright, guys.
I think I'm gonna call it here though.
Because I gotta get going.
Ah, I'm so sorry!
Dang it!
The rev wasn't a replicant.
You messed up!
But we shall finish...
Maybe I will even...
Finish tomorrow.
Feel like we don't have that much left.
So...
No.
Jessica thank you so much for the time gift!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Do I go so much for the pig?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Looks like Mint didn't want to get ran out.
Wait, let me make sure I save before I actually... before I actually start leaving and stuff.
But yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for the help.
Again, I apologize for me mostly just running around being like...
But I hope you had fun.
I hope you had fun.
Chase, thank you so much.
Thank you guys for the super test.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And um, yeah.
You have good taste?
I know.
No, I'm just kidding.
Thank you though.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
There was somebody that commented.
Sorry if you, if you're watching and I don't remember who, what your name was.
But there was somebody that commented and was just like, I wonder if Minto played low, a Sierra load runner.
Um, with, with, with Papa Minto 2.
And I was like...
I looked it up cause I was like, what is that?
And then I saw the pictures and I was like...
Oh my God!
I did play that.
So I'll probably play that next week.
Cause I was like, oh my gosh, no way.
The absolute like nostalgia wave that came over me.
Was crazy!
Take care of me.
You can always tell us if you're having a hard time.
We'll always be there for you.
Thank you.
I'd rather...
I, I try not to because I would much rather just be like, you know, silly, silly entertainer, dumb person on the internet than, than that.
Sorry, I was just, sorry if you heard that.
That was my throat spray.
Hahaha.
But um...
Ah, okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm, I really gotta go.
But Otsubito!
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will see you next time!
Wait!
Next stream is...
If I don't stream this tomorrow, as like a gorilla, next stream, that would be my anniversary!
And I have an announcement!
I have an announcement.
Positive.
Hahaha.
For once.
I have a karaoke and announcement.
And it won't be a very long karaoke.
So, um...
You can hear the announcement, probably towards the end of the stream.
Which probably won't be super duper long.
So, yeah!
Yeah!
Woohoo!
Okay!
Otsubito!
Bye bye!
I don't remember if I said, but thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out!
Thank you guys!